[Music]
Hollywood lined up lots of high-profile
horror projects in 2017 from a revival
of the Saw franchise to a creepy new
take on Stephen King's it and in 2018 if
there seems to be plenty more from where
that came from
strap in because the future looks dark
in the best possible way a quiet place
plot details for a quiet place are being
kept tightly under wraps in advance of
its April twenty eighteenth release but
screenwriters Scott back in bryan woods
have been on an upward trajectory ever
since they earned a top 50 spot in Matt
Damon and Ben Affleck's Project
greenlight competition while their 2015
debut feature nightlight wasn't
particularly well received their spec
script for this new project was good
enough to be purchased outright by
Paramount Plus it attracted Hollywood
power couple John Krasinski and Emily
Blunt who will be on screen together for
the first time unless you count this
oscar-worthy performance on late-night
TV
you're not married anymore Slender Man
veteran TV director Sylvain white
Wilhelm this adaption of one of the most
well known internet memes of all time
the Slender Man has stalked the web
since 2009 when a Photoshop contest
produced a picture of the tall thin
faceless stalker of hapless children
Sony's Screen Gems has slated Slender
Man for release on May 18th 2018 and
while details are scant on the film's
plot lovers of creepy internet memes
have a pretty good idea of what to
expect meg Meg is a joint American
Chinese production whose title doesn't
really give away a whole lot unless you
know that meg is short for Megalodon a
giant prehistoric shark the film's
international cast will portray a
deep-sea research team that comes nose
to nose with a terrifying creature when
their submersible craft is disabled
Jason Statham stars as a Navy captain
and an expert diver with Rainn Wilson
and Ruby Rose and supporting roles
the Chinese lead Li Bingbing is a
veteran actress who you might recognize
from the Transformers and Resident Evil
series we'll have to wait until August
10th 2018 to get a look at Meg but that
look will be in 3d IMAX and will involve
Jason Statham fighting a giant shark so
of course it'll be worth the wait
cadaver Shay Mitchell makes the jump
from TVs Pretty Little Liars to
big-screen [ __ ]
with cadaver an intriguing project also
starring castles stana katic Mitchell
stars as a more technician and disgraced
former cop whose late night shifts take
a turn for the sinister and she receives
a badly brutalized corpse kind of like
this you'll see human heads without
bodies audiences will have to wait until
August 24th 2018 to get a look at
cadaver but director Dietrich van Rijn
is already on to his next project he's
tapped to handle an upcoming remake of
Alfred Hitchcock's classic The Byrds
Halloween reboots of classic horror
franchises haven't exactly been
cinematic gold in recent years with new
installments of Nightmare on Elm Street
and Friday the 13th leaving fans
wondering if these franchises were
better off dead since Rob Zombie remade
Halloween in 2007 and did a sequel to it
in 2009 we understand if you're not too
excited about a new Halloween but here's
the thing you should be for one key
reason this is my moment eastbound and
down star Danny McBride and producer
David Gordon Green came together to work
on the new film which will serve as a
sequel for the first two films I think
tension is what it's all about is
keeping that tension in keeping people's
stomach in knots Michael Myers will
return at theaters on October 19 2018
just in time for the scariest night of
the year
The Strangers - The Strangers was a
surprise hit in 2008 and that many fans
were expecting the second installment
which was announced way back in 2009 to
actually see the light of day but a
decade after the first film in theaters
it's coming with original director
johannes robert and writer bryan bertino
on board Christina Hendricks leads the
cast of the film which has an as-yet
undetermined release date into one
18 what we do know is that it reportedly
takes place at a trailer park in the
middle of nowhere
during a power outage where an
appearance by sac head and pin-up girl
would definitely be something to scream
about nas farhat to the witch is widely
considered to be among the scariest
films of 2015 a unique and ambitious
debut by director robert Eggers and for
his follow-up Eggers is not scaling back
on his ambition he'll be helming a
remake of the seminal 1922 horror
classic nods ferrata
an undertaking only attempted once
before in 1979 by acclaimed German
filmmaker Werner Herzog's Eggers is a
lifelong fan of the original film has
even mounted a stage production twice
it's safe to say that the remake is in
very good hands and if the witch is any
indication fans might be in for the
creepiest vampire flick in years
abruptio Buffy the Vampire Slayer's
James Marsters stars in this intriguing
film playing it down on his luck regular
Joe who wakes up one morning with a bomb
implanted in his neck and there's one
hell of a twist you can imagine but
they're all involved that's right all
the film's roles will be performed by
life-sized realistic latex puppets and
it's got a hell of a supporting cast
including comedian turned horror
mastermind Jordan Peele
of rusty Oh will hit theaters sometime
in 2018 and we can only hope we're ready
[Music]
Winchester
now this looks really cool Winchester is
inspired by the true and very bizarre
story of firearm heiress
Sarah Winchester whose mansion is the
stuff of legend a house crowded in
mystery and speculation a house that has
been the source of one of the most
unusual legends in California history
Winchester supposedly believed that the
ghosts of people killed by her family's
firearms would haunt her forever
unless she never stopped building
rotating ships of carpenters worked on
the mansion until Winchester's death in
1922
creating an endless series of rooms
nooks in the hallways little corridors
that maybe once went somewhere if it
wasn't a constant safety cover that the
unusual really never stops in this house
the upcoming film is a supernatural
period piece written and directed by
identical twins peter and michael
spierig who were behind the 2009 sci-fi
horror thriller day breakers but key to
this project is the casting of Helen
Mirren in the lead role
bringing the kind of acting chops that
can elevate any material Winchester is
slated for release on February 23rd 2018
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]